now this rhinoceros Viper bears a
warning on its head for those who know
the species this giant arrow screams
contains lethal venom look out danger
danger I'm going to bite kill and eat
you whereas this vine snake is more
subtle it has a super bright day glow
ton that contrasts with its dull colored
magnificently camouflaged body come on
could you tell the snake from the tree
branch if you weren't looking for it it
can play possum and lay in wait for prey
but when it itself becomes prey that's
where the tongue comes in suddenly this
green tree branch sticks out its bright
orange tongue that says 10 mess with me
yeah sure if you want a great big tooth
full of poison thing is the vine snake
is not venomous but the Predators don't
need to know that nice trick huh but
here's the trickiest snake of all the
two-headed snake you talk about crafty
defense and office this is the tale of
the two-headed snake the tail looks more
like the head than the head
the false head quote keeps guard sitting
on the coils while the real head sneaks
off looking for food now here's the real
head it has no distinguishing features
those are on the tail this means that a
predator is likely to attack the tail
instead of a head thinking the tail is
the head instead of the head being the
tail just to complete the confusing
illusion the tail actually mimics the
defensive strikes made by the head of a
retreating snake so ends the tail of the
snake with a headlight tail and a tail
like head